welcome to this video playing bingo
Bongo bingo bango let's see I can do
maybe something else here not all Queens
gambit anymore maybe this so that I have
c4 and special a six maybe I get in
95-92 something check like that Oh is
giving this check yeah 92 94 is a bit
awkward ok I'm going to play ac4 this is
also also possible
ok so we are going to get hanging pawns
one of us ok I'll be the one with the
hanging pawns if he takes on the form
I'm not sure yep going to do that yeah
he's got bishop on t 6 and 9 27 this is
not it's not clear that this is such a
great sadness set up against the hanging
pawns there is little pressure on the
pawns no maybe giving giving me the
bishops
yeah I was unsure maybe a 3m even a
three okay and let's let's let him take
there oh it doesn't
okay so it's a bit bit awkward that I
don't get the Queen moving because f3
always on the fire I also like to play
Knight be five but not possible okay
maybe h3y look cookie three or something
like that right difficult position okay
oh oh this is not good running right
onto the end to the into this trick how
bad is it okay I need to take this the
second can play right away maybe it's
not so bad I've got I've got an active
position at least i have c 6
c6 I guess I'm yeah I'm still a bit
irritated from the game before if you
watched the game before this with modern
been only that I had where the other the
black player totally miss played the
whole opening and everything he
afterwards told me he was clearly better
the hallway which was quite quite
irritating I mean you could argue with
unclear anything but stating black would
be that wet black was clearly better the
whole game is is really am yeah how to
how to really a hard to commend upon um
okay rook to the age I would like to
play Bishop Knight B fire but there's
always this rope hanging here hmm
awkward maybe this one then the night be
5 i'm also covering against possible
rookie to move
he's running right into night beehive
here oh I see what is he doing again
said rookie for anything but okay i'm
going to i also have 95 by the way
I might now be this assist the spin on
the diagonal ok this is this is good
rookie fall is also is 96cm isn't this
winning yeah this is winning hear
something a queen I guess or some some
heavy material and c5 I guess getting on
f7
ok trying to from trying to crash
through now broke the eight I have to
check and maybe queen f3 coming just let
the check and queen f3 if he takes on be
too i take f5 with the win he has the
check here but then King edge to and
still f5 hangs yeah there should be
should be good not attacking the rook
though it's protected by a six but f5 is
really that's really serious check g6 I
think I can take
no g6 getting the b2 Bishop into play
decisively on NYE g5 is also strong g
694 so it's so very very strong it's
maybe the strongest all nite nite lag
where's that yeah the various various
wins that was a strange game I totally
overlooked 95 maybe it wasn't wasn't
such a big problem but I totally
overlooked it was a big of a shock that
this was coming probably probably this
is good form idea may other comp is
giving white 0.7 0.8 0.7 it's not not
clear I know it's getting lower a very
very unclear situation i read this is
see that seems to be bad you 2nite be
five years yeah and now black probably
it's minus-2 already he probably needs
to give up give up the exchange em yeah
that's the exchange for porn black can
still hang on here comp is very
optimistic as usual with plus 3 it's not
that easy though but here 96 is really I
think of when would you one age six
check and yeah I found the best move
here it's the best the best sequence
also for the comp here I thought Knight
g4 96 seems to win but I thought this
would win as well okay I can play here
and hang on a bit with okay this is this
is this is a win okay thanks for
watching